welcome back to the free Cod Camp
podcast I'm Quincy Larson teacher and
founder of free Cod camp and each week
we talk with developers entrepreneurs
and ambitious people who are getting
into Tech today I'm joined by Bo KS he
is a software engineer he is a teacher
and he oversees the free code Camp
YouTube channel he's joining us from
Grand Rapids Michigan USA so welcome B
hey Quincy thanks for having me on yeah
we're stoked to have you here and uh
since this is our first video podcast I
created a very quick theme song for the
free Cod cam podcast which I'm going to
attempt to play right now free
Cod free Camp podcast with
Quin all right nice so let me me turn
off my amp
there and
uh and we're going to dive into the
interview so uh of course Bo you've
worked with free cocan for like five
years or something like that um y so you
and I have so much shared context we've
talked hundreds of hours probably but
we're going to attempt to like dive
deeper into your background maybe we can
start off by talking about your
childhood and like where you grew
up yeah sure uh I grew up in Michigan in
Portage Michigan it's just about an hour
away from where I'm living now and I uh
one thing that kind of there's a few
things that actually relate to what I'm
doing now which is um my my dad got me a
a q basic book uh when I think I was in
maybe middle school or I can't even
remember exactly how old I was and then
I would uh do it like I think it was
called GW basic on on my computer and it
was basically just for fun I never even
really thought about it as a job at that
time and then in in high school I was
actually in a video production class and
that that actually got me into to doing
video and but like at the time I I had
no obviously had no idea what was coming
uh what I was going to be doing later in
life but uh just looking back on th
those two experiences actually uh
impacted me a lot as far as my my
direction and where I'm at now yeah I
can imagine and I didn't realize that
you grew up in Michigan there's this
like General kind of rule that like most
people live within 4 hours of where
their mom lives at least in America
that's like people Americans will move
up to four hours away from their mom and
that's like the farthest will generally
move uh and that's true for me I live in
Dallas Texas and of course I grew up in
Oklahoma City which is slightly less
than 4 hours drive away so I think it
it's interesting that you grew up just
an hour away from from where you
ultimately settled and bought your home
and and started your family so that's
that's really cool yeah and and speaking
of family you've got a pretty big family
you've got uh several kids three kids
right yeah I I yeah I have three kids my
oldest is 11 my youngest is uh six and a
half and they're just they're all boys
they're very energetic and I just that's
one of my favorite things to do is just
to hang out with my kids yeah so Family
Man both corns well um I want to dive
into of course uh we can learn a lot
more about your interesting personal
life but I think for people that have
watched the Freo Camp YouTube channel
you've probably seen Bo doing the
introductions for most of the video
courses that we publish and Bo himself
you probably taught I don't know at
least a dozen different courses maybe
two dozen on different WordPress
Concepts mongodb lots of python related
courses you taught like the very popular
JavaScript course that's on free Cod
Camp uh I was surprised to learn that
you actually have a formal educational
background in video production maybe you
can tell us a little bit about that and
what inspired you to go on that
route yeah sure I kind of talked a
little bit about it when I I took T took
the video production class in high
school and that's actually my my first
degree I got a Bachelor's degree in
video production at a Traditional
fouryear School in Michigan and I
actually worked in video production for
a little while and then I kind of
decided I wanted a job where I was uh
interacting with people more making more
of an impact and I decided to go back to
school for teaching and I was an
elementary school teacher and I taught
all the way up through high school and I
I really enjoyed that for a little while
and um I guess most teachers I guess the
average length is about five years that
that they that they're a teacher and
about after about 5 years I started uh
thinking about some other things I think
I got a little bit burnt out on that and
I really like working with youth but I
wanted to do it kind of on the side and
not as my full-time job and that's what
I kind of decide to uh pursue software
development where I never thought about
it previously but I had a little bit of
experience uh when I was younger like I
was saying and I got a degree in
software development and now um I never
really thought about this at the time
but now I realize I'm kind of combining
all those things video production
teaching and software all when it comes
to like teaching courses on
YouTube yeah it's I it's hard to imagine
like a better type of you know job for
you than running the free C cam
Community YouTube channel because you do
get to not only be a teacher but you get
to also work with other teachers and at
the same time you get to apply all your
software engineering knoow from working
as an engineer and also from of course
like going to this computer science
program your computer science program
was uh I guess non-traditional in the
sense that it's an undergraduate degree
program but you were able to complete it
very quickly and very
inexpensively and you did that uh
through Western Governor's University
and I've in the show notes the uh
description below I've linked to an
article where you talk about essentially
how you like completed the entire degree
in about 6 months maybe you can give us
some background and how you were able to
do
that yeah so one cool thing about
Western govern's University is that you
kind of can go at your own pace so every
class either has a final exam where you
usually take it like an exam Center or a
final project that's that's graded by
some graders and if you pass the exam or
pass the final project you can pass the
course and you can basically work at
your own pace so I if you want you can
go do it very very quickly and I already
talked about how it's kind of kind of
burnt out on teaching I was just very
motivated to move on to something new
and that kind of gave me the motivation
to uh basically go as quickly as
possible through this this degree so I
just I just really scheduled out my day
where I had a very strict schedule of of
when I was going to work on uh my cour
work and I was able to stick to that
schedule really well and I had every I
had very distinct goals like I'm going
to pass this class by this date this
class by this date and I would kind of
rearrange like if I felt like oh I'm not
going to meet my goal then I would
either maybe uh stay up later maybe not
do something with friends or there were
actually a few times where I took a day
off of work um as a teacher just so I
could meet my goal to uh to pass the
class by a certain deadline so I just
like got through it super quick and you
pay uh for every six months so I only
had to pay for one one six Monon period
because I was able to get through it so
quickly it did help I I did have some
classes transfer in and I did have um I
guess some a little bit of prior
knowledge in programming so that kind of
helped a little bit too yeah and my
understanding is one of the reasons you
were doing this was because as a teacher
you had student loan debt forgiveness
after a certain amount of service as a
teacher uh yeah quite enough student
loans so if I really want to take
advantage of this I should actually get
some more student loans uh so I can get
them forgiven and uh the truth is I
don't know for sure if I would have ever
done the degree in software development
if I didn't have that motivating me at
first I was actually thinking about
doing a masters in mathematics uh I
thought that would actually kind of go
along with what I was already doing
maybe would open up to teas at a
community college but uh I ended up uh
switching to software development and
that's and I'm really glad I did because
I'm I've been really enjoying my current
role
yeah wow so essentially you kind of got
a free accredited computer science
degree in six months because it was
money that you didn't ultimately have to
spend out of pocket because it was it
was already on the on the I guess
chopping block for getting uh reimbursed
essentially by the government yeah
that's that's true yeah that's pretty
cool it's very resourceful and I think
that that like hints to the general
resourcefulness of
boars uh in general like you're an
extremely like Scrappy uh make do with
little type guy and that that's always
kind of like impressed me about you um I
I've really enjoyed like reading about
you in like the the newspaper for
example like I think what city were you
living in where you you were able to
like uh move into like a an old home and
like fix it up and uh I I know that I
read about it in like a local newspaper
cuz I was like Googling you at one
point yeah yeah so yeah we used to to
live in sagna and uh and in in both
sagna and Grand Rapids we did kind of
choose to live in kind of a more lower
income neighborhood and I've both places
I've kind of gotten involved with a
local community center like in Grand
Rapids I'm on the board of directors of
this local community center that's doing
a lot of work with the youth in the
neighborhood I try to volunteer there so
I just uh I guess I just have a desire
to use my my time to kind of give back
to other especially Youth and yeah there
was a an article when we live in sagna
the news back when there was a printed
newspaper we we had an article in the
printed newspaper about what we were
doing in sagona yeah
well your desire to continue to teach of
course comes through in the YouTube
channel but my understanding is you also
run a um my daughter's like scowling at
me she's scowling take my phone
here you want my phone all right here
I'll just leave it here she loves to
take it and then watch Zelda tears of
the Kingdom related videos um I've been
playing with that with my kids right now
we always have like a family game that
we do with the kids or something that we
do like a few times a week and we're
doing tears of the Kingdom right now
awesome yeah I've heard it's an amazing
game like a Sandbox type game where you
can yeah we just take turns playing we
all watch and then we kind of take turns
like the kids will play then I'll play
so that's pretty cool yeah and we did
that with breath of the wild but I just
got so burnt on zeld though I was oh let
me do like anything else so I haven't
played Tis of the Kingdom at all and it
gives me like uh kind of like a a nice
like they'll come in and they'll say
Daddy can you help me beat this boss
like I've never even played that game
it's like the get out of jail free card
so I can keep working while they uh
while they play on their switch but um
one of the things that is really cool
because you seem to have this desire to
help out in the community and and also
to teach kids is is that you're also
still actively involved in
robotics um in robotics club and and
teaching youth uh about like programming
and Robotics through through this can
you talk about that a little bit yeah
yeah so for quite a like back when I was
in Sagen I started this before I even
had kids of my own actually uh coaching
a first robotics team so first robotics
um is a an organization that's basically
all over the world and they do uh local
robotics competitions and there's
different levels there's like Elementary
School level Middle School level high
school level and so I've been coaching
teams for quite a while now including
this year I coached the team and so now
I get to actually coach the team that my
kids are on so when I first started uh I
was coaching just only other people
other kid like other kid kids from other
families which I still enjoyed and now
it's kind of my kids are old enough to
be able to uh be on teams and so it's
something I I really enjoy doing where
uh there's kind of different levels uh
this year it was the the first Lego
League where we build a Lego robot and
then there's a a 8ot x 4 foot table with
all these stations on it and there's we
have to program a robot to accomplish
objectives at different stations and
then at the competition all the schools
have been basically preparing their
robots to do the exact same uh the exact
same object objectives and then we see
at the competition who can score the
most points by doing all the objectives
on the table and it's all autonomous you
have to pre-program the robot so you
can't really control it with a
controller and so it kind of uses it
helps the kids learn programming so I'm
able to kind of use uh some of my
programming uh skills and teaching
skills to be able to teach the the the
kids how to do some basic programming
with the robots yeah I know you have a
passion for robots in general and in
fact you in addition to being father of
three and running the free Camp
Community YouTube channel you have
another Channel which is quite popular
called robot family maybe you could talk
a little bit about the origin of that
channel and what your goals are with
it yeah uh so I have this channel called
robot family it's um the target audience
is is families and basically younger
audience and I primarily feature fun
scripted stories with robot toys as
characters and I started it probably
about about uh five years ago I just had
a I just had a robot named Cosmo it's
just like a a cool robot toy and I I had
the idea I wanted to I want basically I
wanted something fun to do with my kids
and I also wanted to see if there's some
if I could eventually get companies to
send our family free robots uh for our
kids to use and it's worked out exactly
like that exactly as planned so I I I
started this Channel and we started Ed
by doing at first we were just like I
was buying robots and we were doing kind
of unboxings and and showing them and
pretty quickly I was able to get
companies to send us some some robots
for the channel and then eventually we
kind of transitioned to not not we we
started like we wen't eventually we
don't do unboxings anymore we just do
these fun scripted stories with the
robots as characters and it's kind it's
the Channel's continued to grow it has
over 250,000 subscribers now
and I'm and even this year I'm kind of
trying to um uh bring it to the next
level basically where like I was start I
was I've been kind of uh Rel sometimes
inconsistent with the posting schedule
but I already have a goal this year to
to to post one a year and I'm just
trying or no one one one video a month
one main video a month and then maybe
some other like minor vid like less less
time intensive videos where in the past
sometimes it wasn't even that many
videos and so now I actually I'm
developing a better system where I'm now
hiring people to write the the videos
and hiring people to edit the videos so
I just have to suit the videos and that
allows me to kind of put out more
content uh it would be one thing if I
was doing it full-time but since it's
just like a side project I don't have
like all the time to kind of invest so I
try to figure out how can I uh make my
time like stretch stretch more where
what can I do that what what things can
I hire out so I can basically produce
more content so it's been going pretty
well yeah and it's interesting that
you're finding people to help you with
that have you uh being somebody who's
interested in robotics and automation
have you uh made use of automation very
much for running
or um you know any aspect of the
production of that
channel
um
no I
think I haven't done a lot of Auto
automating things besides just like like
I said trying to kind of get a a good
system for how I can
um have someone write it have someone
edit and then once once I it was hard to
implement a system of having people help
at first because the way I was shooting
the videos it was very hard to have
someone to edit it based on how I was
shooting the videos CU I had to remember
all these things in my head but then I
realized is I'm going to actually have
to really change the system so it can be
more efficient so that's not really
automating but it's kind of related
where really thinking about the system
in place that's going to make the the
process go smoother and easier awesome
yeah well um I like to think of it as
like you can you can delegate and you
can automate and like either of those
two things can help you ultimately
concentrate on whatever it is that
you're kind of where you're adding the
most value to whatever the output is uh
I guess the thing that's closest to uh
automating which I do use chat GTP to
help out the channel like chat GTP will
help me uh think of script ideas I've
even written a few uh videos with chpt I
did one where um we had a our we have a
yearly tradition of a Christmas video
where our kids are in our kids aren't in
all the videos but they are in some
videos and we have a weekly a yearly
Christmas tradition where the all the
presents get stolen and it's a mystery
to see how to find find the presents we
just had our fourth annual and this year
I was kind of inspired by uh like the
night night before Christmas and these
other poems and I was like what if what
if the entire video was rhyming couplets
so I actually um I I got the I got a
script I actually hired someone to write
a script and then I put it into chat gbt
and said convert this to Rhymes so so
then it it converted the the script to
to all rhyming couplets and then I did I
had to do some tweaking to make it some
part sound better but I I realized
that's that's actually a good use out of
chap peti to convert something into
Rhymes and then we the whole video is a
rhyming video very cool yeah that's a
that's the first time I've heard of
someone basically taking a script and
turning it into a rhyming kind of poem
one of the interesting things
about teaching as a discipline is that
you yourself have to have really good
Mastery of the subject before you can
really teach it and in some ways
teaching further solidifies your own
understanding of it what have you really
enjoyed the most about teaching and
about preparing like instructional
design essentially video courses putting
them out
there yeah you're right that teaching
can help you learn things and that's
actually How I Learned JavaScript kind
of I mean I I already kind of got when I
was first learning to code I had already
went through a lot of the fre free code
Camp curriculum that's actually the main
way I learned JavaScript but then I
decided to start my own personal YouTube
channel before I was involved with free
code camp where I would teach little uh
bits of JavaScript it's called JS
nuggets and every video is like a
different JavaScript concept and that's
really how I really started to learn
JavaScript it was like I I I knew I
already kind of knew knew about it but
to actually teach it I had to research
and make sure I make I really understood
it to be able to actually teach it to
other people and that's kind of
continued as I work with the free Camp
Channel and create courses um I
definitely obviously have to know the
content before I'm able to teach it and
so it's kind of a great motivator to
learn new technologies and to to learn
new things when I know I'm going to
teach a course on this topic so I have
to kind of Deep dive into the content
the topic I have to like kind of try out
on myself and really kind of come to a
good understanding before I could teach
it to others so that's that's one of the
things I like about creating courses is
is just learning new things and and
solidifying my knowledge and then just
being able to help others by be abl to
kind of share what I've learned about
about that technology so in a way uh the
the fact that the course has to come out
is kind of like an ex extrinsic
motivator for you to really understand
things and make sure you're getting
things right because when you publish a
video course it's not like uh publishing
an article where somebody points it out
and you can just go easily update it
it's pretty hard to update YouTube
videos uh YouTube is is pretty
unforgiving in terms of being able to do
like Insite to edits right um have you
have you experienced a situation where
you got something wrong on YouTube and
like what did you
do well that's definitely a motivator to
when you're learn something something on
your own uh and you're using it if you
make a little mistake uh nobody really
knows you made that mistake but if
you're if you're learning something to
teach a course about it and then you
make the course if you make mistake
everyone knows that you made that
mistake so that kind of motivates you to
um make sure you have it right but
definitely I've still made mistakes I've
um uh created courses that had uh errors
in it and then uh people you know
they're always quick to point them out
in in the comments but I think it's kind
of a Growing Experience you know I mean
it's well first of all is it is kind of
embarrassing to put out there like and
do something wrong but I I'm I my goal
is to kind of uh learn from everybody
and and so I try if people are pointing
that out I try to kind of I try to
internalize that and actually try to
learn from instead of getting defensive
I really try to learn and then I
sometimes if it's on a on a video I can
either put on the description or a
comment how to like what the mistake was
or YouTube did kind of recently come out
with a feature called Corrections where
you can make it so a card pops up to say
when there's a correction in the video
yeah you can't actually change the video
itself although you could edit that
section out completely
right yeah so YouTube does have a
feature where you can remove sections of
a video but you can never add sections
of a video yeah so and even if you're
doing this I mean let's say you publish
something on free Cod Camp which you
know has a lot of people watching it
every day and you it's a multi-hour
course and you need to make some sort of
edit where you remove something that is
factually incorrect or something like
that it takes a while for that change to
propagate through YouTube in me in the
meantime it could be hours and hours
thousands of people watching something
that you know is wrong
right that happens
sometimes yeah yeah so yeah if you make
a if you remove a section with the
YouTube editor it can take a few hours
before the new version shows up and
there are there have been times I I
don't know if with any of my videos but
there have definitely been times where
we've posted a course and uh a mistake
uh we realize a mistake and then we take
it down and and re republish it and
sometimes the mistake isn't from the
course creator sometimes the mistake is
on my end where I I made a mistake when
I was uh putting the course together
where some some contributors to the free
C Camp Channel just give me a video
that's already ready to post but then
some contributors uh will give like lots
of little videos I have to edit together
some cours that we publish require a lot
more work on my end than others and
every once in a while there will I will
will do something wrong and we'll have
to take the course down and republish it
but luckily it doesn't happen too often
uh but there there that's always an
option that we can we can remove a
course and republish but we we don't
like to do that yeah well one of the
things about free Camp's YouTube channel
this is a little bit unique on YouTube
is the sheer size of the courses we're
publishing a lot of creators will
publish like 20 minute videos um maybe
even on hour video essays but it's
pretty rare that people are uploading a
you know eight hour course or something
like that to YouTube and over the years
you figured out lots of compression
tricks to be able to upload larger and
larger videos to the extent that I think
you uploaded a video that was more than
4 days long uh a few like a month or two
ago right like the uh the AWS boot camp
uh video course yeah that that was
massive and maybe you can talk a little
bit about how you figure out ways to do
this because even YouTube their
Engineers are kind of often asking H how
did you do that you know we we've had
lots of calls with like the you know VP
of XYZ over YouTube who's trying to
understand like how we're using it and
how we're using it in such a different
way from how most people are using
YouTube as a distribution
Network yeah our Channel definitely does
things on YouTube that other channels
aren't doing and yeah like you said
people from YouTube have kind of uh
talked to said that we're kind of a an
edge case for for what we're doing and
especially when our Channel when our
Channel first started even less people
were were cting these long courses I
think now that we've the free C Camp
channel has shown how how uh how much
people actually like that there's more
and more channels posting long courses
and yeah i' I've it's it does get tricky
I mean for one you YouTube's official
documentations says that the longest
course possible is 12 hours and that's
just not true they just I don't know why
it's still out there but that they their
help page that's what that says so
sometimes you you just have to try
things to see if it works even if the
the documentation says it's not going to
work and uh but one thing that is true
is the the file size limit so I think I
think it's 250 gigabytes and so that so
that's one of the biggest things that we
have to work around because like this
4-day course um uh as you can imagine
it's it's hard to fit that into a uh 250
Gigabyte file so the really the biggest
secret is um the webm format uh I don't
know this for sure but I I think that
YouTube that's like the webm format I
think is the main format YouTube uses
internally um and it seems like the webm
format can compress things a lot more
and still have pretty good quality so
especially when I'm creating any course
that's like over 24 hours long it it
takes me a long time to finally get that
course up because I'll have to sometimes
I'll have to export multiple sometimes
I'll have to export multiple files uh
from my video editing software because
it cannot uh my video editing software
cannot export over 24 hours at a time so
and then then I'll have to use another
like FF imp or something to combine
those those exports and then I'll have
to use I usually use handbreak to
convert it to the webm format and then
after then I after all that's done I
have I mean it takes up so so much SP
face I mean sometimes it can be up to up
to like sometimes it can get up to like
a terabyte you know all these files and
then um and then I'll finally get to
upload the file to YouTube and sometimes
like one when we first published the
cs50 course which was like a a pretty it
was a pretty long course 24 25 hours
long for the new one the newest one and
it's in 4k yeah yeah so that that was um
the biggest thing about the Cs 50
courses this it was 4K So Not only was
it a super long course it was also 4K
and this newest one didn't take as long
but the first one we published that was
also similar length we published I think
maybe two years ago it took it took
actually I think four to five weeks to
process on YouTube after it uploaded it
it had to finish processing and it took
over four weeks of process and then I I
had given up on it I just I didn't think
it was ever going to finish processing
by just left it there just in case and
eventually it showed up showed that it
was done processing and then we could
publish it wow that's got to be a record
like I I can't imagine that YouTube I
mean their Engineers hats off to them if
they actually have they don't have
something that kills a process after
four weeks because that that is like
some crazy processing time for uh a
single video um they must have improved
it though cuz uh since then I I haven't
the processing time isn't never that
long it still can be kind of a a long
time time like for that 4-day course I
think that took maybe like a day to
process which is still a long time but
nowhere near like the the the four weeks
so yeah yeah
so maybe you can talk a little bit about
how you approach developing courses
because as I said you've developed a lot
of courses uh we have a lot of uh
organizations we work with you know uh
Microsoft Google uh and then of course
lots of uh
tech companies like mongodb New Relic
and they'll create grants for free Cod
camp and the grant will be like create a
course around open Telemetry for example
and show how it works or or something
like that and then essentially Your Role
is to take a look at the various tools
and figure out okay what's like a full
stack project we can build around this
that will be compelling that will be
interesting and we can show people how
to use these tools in addition to a
whole bunch of other open source tools
so maybe you could talk about what your
workflow is like like let's say for
example um the spoiler alert we're going
to be developing a course on this
multiplayer uh server like net code
essentially and that's going to be
pretty exciting uh but like what will be
your process for developing a game that
makes use of net code and and things
like that and I guess from ideation to
actual you know outline development uh
the more detail you can go into the
better cuz I I think a lot of people are
probably very interested in how the
video courses get made because they
don't just like drop out of the sky in
like final form they are it there's a
long iterative process involved
knowledge you I didn't if there's any
other videos out there I'll watch videos
that kind of explain it and then just
get get as much knowledge of that that
technology as possible possible and then
sometimes there'll be an opportunity to
actually um ask questions to the team
that creates that technology and so it
to kind of really solidify my
understanding and then after that I try
to think of what an interesting project
is going to be because uh we want we
want to teach the teach the topic but in
an engaging way so I want to kind of
think what's going to be an an
interesting project that people are
going to be maybe interested to create
even even if they're they don't know
about that technology or they're not
maybe so we you you want to be able to
have people coming to the video for two
two reasons one people that want to
learn that technology and two maybe they
just are interested in that project so
you get more more interest in that and
then after I kind of developed the idea
maybe brainstorm different things then I
will um uh I I guess maybe depending on
the course I may have to develop some
some code uh some like the code for the
project that I'm going to teach each and
then some times then I'll generally have
to write a script and the script will
they'll usually some sort of
introduction and a key part is having a
good hook you know you want within the
first 30 seconds or a minute uh you want
people to be interested in watching uh
the the rest of the course where where
uh sometimes I'll actually do that uh
I'll have an idea for what I'm going to
do for the hook and the introduction but
I'll do that at the end after I've Maybe
demonstrated how to create a project
then I'll then I'll write the
introduction and put a lot of time into
how I'm going to hook people so they're
actually interested in watching the
whole thing and uh the way I do courses
everyone kind of makes them different
but generally I the most of the course I
won't be on camera I'll be demonstrating
something uh through screen sharing and
I'll be just recording my voice and then
I'll I'll generally have just certain
sections where I'm on camera so I'll use
like like the introduction the
conclusion and then maybe a few
transition points so I'll write all that
and then uh like what I'm going to do
for that then I record it all and then I
just basically kind of combine it all
together um edit out all my mistakes
like anytime I anytime I'm sharing my
screen and uh on a course you can know
that there's way more edits than it
looks like because uh I make so many
mistakes when I'm creating it but then I
have to edit it so makes it looks like
I'm knew what I was talking about on the
first take so uh it kind of can take a
while to put it all together um I mean
also there's a few things I always think
about which is one having good audio and
I mean that's a super important thing
for for courses is having good audio and
then uh one thing that's kind of
surprising to people is that on the free
Cod Camp channel onethird of our viewers
are watching on mobile devices and even
more than one3 there are sometimes
watching on very small screens cuz we we
have viewers all over the world and we
have um and so it's important for any of
our courses especially ones I'm making
is that the any text or code on screen
is big enough for people to be able to
read if they're watching on a small
device because we want to make this
accessible as possible to people all
over the world so those are all kind of
my I guess some of the broad overview of
what I think about when I'm creating a
course yeah and you've created an entire
guide I I just call it our YouTube style
guide essentially uh how to create a
good technical course um and uh I'm
going to include that in the U the show
notes but what are some of the big
mistakes that you've seen people make
that you think are like the the easiest
things to correct easy wins where people
can up their course creation game if
they just remember a few key Concepts I
mean you definitely mentioned Tech size
you definitely mentioned the importance
of quality sound people will tolerate
like okayish video but if the audio is
bad then that is a lot of people will
just click off YouTube is a very uh
Cutthroat brutal Place uh environment
for your video to live because all along
the side you've got exciting you know
potentially like much more uh
Sensational than like learning how to
use mongod to be or something like that
you got content like that uh that can
easily pull you in your attention away
and then also you know
like Reddit and Facebook and all these
other websites are just an ALT tab away
so people can go and do something
completely different and you know there
people are you know potentially watching
and a on a bus or like there are so many
different kind of things that can jostle
people out of watching your in-depth
course uh but I guess tips you have for
engaging people and uh things that
you've you've seen people do that you
you really learned a lot from and things
that you see people do often that you
think are anti-patterns and are probably
undermining their ability to find and
retain uh viewership and
Learners yeah so I would
say I think I've maybe the here here are
the four biggest things I mean the two
of them would be the ones you already
said so audio quality is really big uh
is really important and a lot of people
um don't put enough thought into that
because you know I'm seeing so so many
people are submitting courses to to me
for the free cam channel so I see all
these different levels so audio quality
and text size are the two very big
things to think about and then just the
the importance of the introduction I
talked about that a little earlier but
some people just go right into uh kind
of teaching without giving anybody a
reason for why they should watch so it's
very important within the first 30
seconds to a minute to explain very
clearly what the course is about what
the people are going to learn why the
why people should watch should want to
learn that that content and why people
should learn that content from you uh
because there's so many courses around
so many different topics so you want
very quickly to explain why someone
should watch that and why someone should
watch it from you and then uh at least
on the free Camp Channel we have viewers
from like I said all over the world
World a lot of viewers don't speak
English as a first language and so it
makes it even more important to have
basically have um speech that are very
easy to understand it could be like
enunciation pronunciation audio quality
um so like if you're a native English
speaker I think it's kind of easier to
understand uh maybe low lower quality
audio but if you if you are kind of an
speaking English as a second language
you're just learning English it becomes
even more important for that to be very
easy to understand so that can really
make a big difference as well so I think
those are those are the the kind of the
four highlevel things that that I would
think about but there's like like I said
you mentioned the Articles there's
plenty of other tips in the article if
people want to learn more yeah okay just
to
recap high quality sound large text an
introduction that establishes like
why um you know the who what where why
but essentially why people should stick
around and invest the time in doing this
course and then uh fourth just
consideration for non-native English
speakers and uh on that note uh you have
been very active in
mentoring
uh estephania who has launched the
Spanish YouTube channel which is also
quite popular it's it's one of the more
popular Spanish language YouTube
channels now and uh you've also been
working very hard on trying to figure
out ways to improve the quality of
subtitles we've asked for lots of
features from YouTube for example when
we talk to YouTube uh localization is a
huge deal what do you think the the near
future for
localization is um maybe you can talk a
little bit about like what Mr Beast has
been doing for example and some of the
other ways that people have been trying
to make their content more accessible to
the non englishing
world yeah one of the relatively new
features that YouTube rolled out was
different language tracks so we can put
we can upload for instance a Hindi
language track or a Spanish language
track so it's it's our main video but
instead of so before you could already
upload different subtitle tracks and you
could change what what language the
subtitles are for but now you can upload
different uh language tracks uh and your
videos and so we we have been
experimenting with that and at our scale
um it's kind of prohibitive to actually
have someone personally read like dub
the the courses so we've been um looking
into various ways to use AI tools and
other things to create these uh these
dubbed voices and I think eventually
YouTube is just going to offer that
automatically like right now uh you have
to upload a different dub track but I my
guess is in the near future YouTube will
have live dubbing in in other languages
right on the
channel yeah and that will be amazing
because uh whenever we we you know the
Spanish Channel everything is done by
Spanish speaking creators and that is
like the very top level of experience is
when you actually have a teacher who
speaks your language who understands you
know not not that like Spanish is a
monoculture culture it's a whole bunch
of different countries but um you know
can make like cultural references and
explain things in a way that like an an
AI generated like translation of a
script won't necessarily capture that
Nuance so um yeah like we're we're going
to continue to create uh video
courses in other world languages even
after such technology exists but it's
it's very exciting just because free
Camp has more than a thousand full
length
courses on I mean
most programming topics like we have a
course on
Cobalt right um we have and we have
courses on all the newest stuff like
pretty pretty much any new technology
Mojo course for example um so you can
imagine
like uh Wikipedia about half the traffic
to Wikipedia goes to the English edition
half the traffic goes to the other world
languages so it's like essentially
doubling the amount amount of impact our
charity can have in terms of our mission
which is helping people learn to code
for free so uh yeah here's hoping that
YouTube rolls those features out and in
the meantime we'll continue
experimenting with them if we can
economically do something to add dubbing
or and certainly if we can we can add uh
new uh
captions you know in in different
languages we're going to do that uh
right now you you can watch free C Camp
in any World Language you want uh with
with the uh Auto translation but
YouTube's interface makes it like four
or five clicks to be able to access that
and they I was just helping somebody
understand that the other day and it's
still you know four or five clicks I
think it's you have to click subtitles
then you have to click English and then
you click the gear again the setting
again and then you go you know trans
autot translate and then you choose your
language so it's like four or five
clicks uh to be able to get captions but
you can do that and I do that all the
time because I watch a lot of videos
that are not in English um like
documentaries and things like that and
uh I'll I'll go and and get the auto
translated English is kind of like a
first class language in the sense that I
think it's fewer clicks for an English
speaker just because it is kind of like
a major world language but um yeah
that's been an incredibly powerful
feature and translation just gets better
and better all the time you know I I
study a lot of languages and I'm just
blown away I talk to I'll I'll take this
and I'll show it to like my wife who's a
CH a native Chinese speaker I'll talk to
my native Spanish speaking friends and
I'll be like does this look like natural
and they'll be like oh yeah that's very
natural where did you get that I'll be
like GPD came up with it you know so uh
yeah it's it's really impressive uh how
powerful these tools are getting and
freeo Camp I'll say it like on both of
our behalf we are applying the latest
and greatest tools as quickly as we can
we're where they're ready for prime time
you know there are lots of experimental
tools that are frankly not ready for
prime time and you won't see us
generally use those um but mature tools
that that do work we are going to adopt
them so what are your um I guess your
biggest what are you most excited about
with the uh the main English Freo Camp
YouTube channel well yeah I'm well first
of all I'm excited that we're getting a
little closer to 10 million subscribers
so that will be like a huge milestone
that I think maybe in the next year or
so we'll get to uh because you know when
I start I when I started working with
free Coke camp we had 75,000 subscribers
so because I a lot some people think I
just started the channel because they
see me so much but I didn't start the
channel that that was Quincy but uh I I
joined when there was 75,000 subscribers
and now we're getting close to 10
million so that's been pretty exciting
but I guess as far as other excitement I
I'm just exciting excited to uh
basically continue what we've been doing
to to post more courses and like what a
lot of my ex is around what you were
just talking about which is getting
making it more access making our courses
more accessible to more people in the
world through uh better subtitles better
dubbing and um just continuing to
experiment with I guess uh different
formats and I just hope that we can
continue to be kind of the the the
premier uh place where people are
watching software tutorials and uh we
also want to kind of continue to publish
more and more very massive comprehensive
courses to the point
where where people don't need to even go
to udemy or some of these other places
because they know they can just go to
the free C Camp YouTube channel and
they'll be able to find a high quality
course and whatever they're trying to
learn absolutely yeah one of the things
that I'm really excited about about the
YouTube channel is that we are
publishing fulllength university courses
to created by free C oh yeah yeah so of
course Bo you were able to go to Western
Governor's University excellent uh
accredited University that's online very
economical there are some other what I
call Ultra lowcost universities out
there here in the United States um but
our goal is to eventually have a free
computer science degree program like a
bachelor in computer science and
associate in mathematics and we're going
to be publishing the lectures from those
on YouTube in fact we already have the
lectures from one of the first
mathematics courses up there and we're
going to get the the lectures from the
second one up hopefully within the next
month or two and then uh we have a total
of 40 full length university courses
that we're going to publish on uh Freo
Camp's YouTube channel so that that's
something I'm I'm really pumped about
that I I'll just add on top of what you
were saying and I'm I'm excited about
that too there's so many things to be
excited about so well I want to talk a
little bit more about you personally
because you're an interesting dude uh
objectively or I guess subjectively cuz
I can't speak objectively but like from
where I'm standing like you're you're
very interesting one of the things that
strikes me is the parallels between you
and Richard feeman of course the famous
I think it was like
Caltech uh mathematics physics Professor
uh one of the greatest teachers to ever
live that we know about you know there
could be incredible teachers in you know
human prehistory and Antiquity that that
are lost of time but he was definitely
like one of the greatest teachers of the
20th century and he was a very uh I
don't mean to say this in like a uh
pejorative way but he was kind of an
eccentric dude like he loved going
really deep and learning like magic
tricks and and you know unicycle and all
this stuff and you are somebody who
literally owns like stilt walking.com or
something was it what's the website that
you have yes yes stil walker. net stilt
walker. net where you can hire anything
with it for a while though you can hire
V CS to be a stilt Walker at your
Carnival or your your state fair right
yeah yeah so I used to do it a lot more
I I haven't been doing it as much lately
if I still sometimes do it where I I I
walk on stilts um I I juggle clubs so I
I'll be on the stilts juggling clubs and
I'll go go to different events and I've
done a lot of parades I've done a lot of
different like fairs and and and
festivities so I I I don't do it quite
as much as I used to but I'm still
getting out there sometimes and I I'm
trying to pass off some of to to my kids
um because another thing I do uh I used
to do a lot was was magic shows and so
um my my son uh my oldest son has been
been this will be his uh this year will
be his fourth year in a row doing a
magic show at his uh school talent show
so I've been kind of passing off some of
my knowledge to him and and and helping
him prepare to to perform to do these uh
these magic performances so um yeah I
there was a while where I was actually
booking a lot like tons of paid gigs and
now now I mainly just do it kind of for
fun at different events but I I there
was a period in my life where I was
booking paid gigs like for still walking
and and magic shows uh like all over the
state of Michigan
so that is really cool yeah uh
definitely if we ever have like a really
like free C Camp is a small charity we
don't have a lot of resources we don't
have like big inperson conferences or
anything it's not like dreamforce that
takes over half of San Francisco that
Salesforce has every year we would never
have the budget for something like that
but if we do ever have like an event
like a you know an Apple keynote type
thing we absolutely have got to get you
on stilts at that event that would be so
cool I'm in I'm in yeah well Bo I just I
really appreciate everything you're
doing for the Freo Camp Community I'm
proud of course to have you on the Freo
Camp team working alongside me and
estephania and all these other uh
teachers SL software Engineers um you
know many of whom have classroom
teaching experience like you have five
plus years of uh special ed teaching and
Robotics club and things like that and
uh yeah we're we're just like thrilled
to have you here it's it's a huge point
of Pride that we can say like yeah we
have people like Bo KS working at free C
Camp so uh yeah I just want to publicly
acknowledge that like I'm you know over
the moon at everything you're doing and
uh I want to thank you again well I
really appreciate it I'm yeah I respect
you so much so just heing all that
coming from you is really meaningful
thank you yeah and I just want to
encourage everybody to check out some of
Bose's writing which I've included in
the show notes uh again uh his story of
how he got his second degree his
computer science uh software development
degree from Western Governor's
University while he was raising two kids
while he was working as a teacher and uh
check out Bo's personal website which
has some some cool quirky stuff on it
and of course if you are a Creator and
you want to create courses or if you're
just a teacher you're teaching at a
community college a university wherever
uh High School level and you just want
to help share your passion and your
wisdom that you've developed around math
programming
technology reach out to Bo and read his
style guide it will teach you everything
he's learned over the course of many
years being on YouTube and creating
tutorials uh and um yeah I hope
everybody has a fantastic day uh signing
off everybody uh till next week happy
coding bye everybody